in hours
we are lives we have having technical
issues that we're becoming a bit of a
nightmare
uh but these things happen what are you
gonna do so we are here we are going to
be talking about Stargate and we're with
Mike hello sir
how you doing
you're Frozen
you're back I'm coming back now I'm
coming back yeah it's all going on my
way
um so how are you first of all Jay we're
going to be talking about Stargate sg1
the best per season how's things over
there picking our favorite episodes from
every single season we haven't decided
or I haven't told each other what those
choices are so I'd be interesting see if
we pick the same ones anywhere I feel
exactly and also Sarah also it might not
be necessarily like the big episode like
uh season finale it might be just an
episode that just rang as a favorite for
an individual I mean each you know we're
all like like different things and some
people like more the more comedic
episodes some people like the um the
more of the actual big kind of arcs and
stuff so yeah this should be good so how
do you want to at least how do you want
to proceed with them well we've got at
least one subscriber that's done an
amazing list as well so I will read his
answers we're going along just because
he spent the time doing the list so I
think the least we can do is read it but
we've got our little intro bits we'll do
that and then we'll crack on and we'll
just start a season one mate let's go
for it
[Music]
right so
I tell you what I will go first because
I'm in charge here uh
yes uh so season one um episode 21 for
me
um is politics and it's it's one of my
favorite episodes of the series because
it just stands out we met Senator Kinsey
who I freaking love
um I just love Ronnie Cox in everything
he's did from Robocop on I just I just
love the guy
um
Jellico in the next generation of course
as well as well again who's one of my
favorite
um I just I'm more than happy for him to
come back
um I love how it's
so we've got these couple of multiple
episodes where we know there's a gold
attack come in Daniel sees it in the um
other
um other time thing so
um he knows it's coming
um but then Kinsey comes in 5.7 billion
dollars to run this program nowadays the
American government spend that on toilet
paper
um what um and they end up shutting down
the program so everyone has to run off
and they have to save the world
it's just a brilliant episode but the
reason why I like it so much
is because I just can't help but think
that's exactly what the American
government would do it's what politicism
I think you could be right about that
yeah I could see that but how and many
other times have we ever seen in a
Sci-Fi show particularly
that they brought that sort of element
of realism in that actually I don't it
just it just I just remember watching
thinking Bloody hellis is clever it's
there's bloody clever that and I'll tell
you what there's multiple episodes where
Stargate you've done that and the
Stargate issue one did that we were
chatting in the um in the um chat before
before while we're waiting for you Mike
and then the one thing was Guy um said
like
um everybody hates those Filler episodes
that people do yeah they like the target
the clip episodes clip shows the clip
shows yeah yeah I'll tell you what
Stargate did that better than anyone the
president episode when they did the
filler one where the president comes in
and going you've been doing what
and Kinsey's in that as well that's
right they did a few actually they did
about four or five clip show episodes
but as you say most um TVs who starred
Star Trek uh I don't Star Trek did they
but I know the Stargate was the one I'm
trying to think actually I don't think
it did
but I know a lot of shows DS9 void never
did but TNG did a couple of fillers oh
they did one the end of season two when
Riker gets that thorn in his side and
they had to go through his mind
and it was like a clip show from seasons
one and two so yes you're right that one
didn't work but um there was a great
episode in season six I think it was the
one where you had the guy that um Dan
castellan left to say the one who plays
does Homer Simpson's voice the guy that
got the um he got the uh the stone and
he was actually connected with Jack
O'Neill that was a clever one we may
discuss that episode a little later
because all right okay that's the one I
thought of when you mentioned that okay
yeah yeah
um but very clever very very very clever
way of
recycling the actual um episode saving
money but also showing the best at that
point of what Stargate sg1 season one
had produced it was a very clever thing
very good so what is yours that's my
first choice anyway politics because
mainly because it was different which is
what I really liked I thought it was
clever how about yourself what is your
first choice for
your favorite episode season one
okay a lot of choices I'm going to go
with solitudes uh the episode 17 of
season one
um it's the one where um Carter and
anneal they think that they are on
another planet they're stranded they
can't get home and of course this was a
very clever setup for future for future
elements where they were actually on a
second Stargate on Earth and
um I just thought it was a very very
clever idea that in all the exploring
they do it never occurred to the team
that they were actually on Earth in the
first place there was a second Stargate
um I like the interaction between
O'Neill and Carter because their
relationship was always clever I like
the idea that they'll start to piece
together that there was like a vibration
at the same time as the um as the gate
activated little wet roll and it was
like an overload
um and it although it wasn't
particularly arc-based I just like the
idea of it being a Twist on the actual
two of the main characters they thought
they were and of course there's a great
scene at the end with Hammond's rescues
them and and Carl says oh you you come
on through this target you come to
rescue us and of course you know he says
like no it's a long story
um and so although
it was just a clever idea I just liked
it and of course it did set up later on
um that the second gate was used in
elements of the show so it's just the
one that worked for me I'm afraid so
that's the one yeah it was such an
important for me that was one of the
First episodes I really remembered that
really stuck out like this is a good
episode this is good Sci-Fi not just
good that this is good sort of thing
um when I first watched it but also the
relationship between Carter and Antonio
like you said that was that's when that
start and I always thought that was when
we started from then on we got O'Neill
we got Richard Dean Anderson's O'Neill
from then on
[Music]
that was when we got him so yeah that
was a great episode because I think also
for that first season Richard Dean
Anderson of course was
um under the influence of the the movie
version of anneal who was a lot more
serious a lot more sort of jaded after
losing his son and of course Richard
Dean allenson's sort of humor
bled through the series and that's what
actually as we will continue will show
how the series had its very unique
identity that sort of it was not awful
comedy-like but it had a very positive
and had a lot of humor
um and yeah I should say it's kind of
like that point where you could see that
he started to make his own personal uh
um interpretation of the character in
SC1 so that's why I liked it it's
actually
um something interesting insisted on
when he agreed to do the series and
obviously he was one of the on the
production company that was making it
you know with them Gekko but he actually
before
I'd love to do this but this character
is I've got to bring some of me into it
and that's where that's how why we got
the O'Neill that's why we get the joke
O'Neill two l's
[Music]
yeah and that's the theory that actually
the Stargate the TV series actually a
different Universe to the movie I've
heard that I
mean it's close but there are some
differences so
um I guess it's how you interpret it
really I mean do you think it's do you
consider it a separate timeline or do
you just accept that there were
differences and just go with it I just
think there's there's differences I'm
not really that bothered but um but yeah
there are different timelines that's in
canon in the series so who knows but but
either way it's a fun it's a fun Theory
absolutely season two we'll crack on
with us sneezing Two For Me episode 17.
did you have an honor didn't you didn't
you have somebody who was actually um
going to be putting in their their call
I've already done that oh yes I did um
one of the subscribers has done so yes
um Ambrose Royal has done season one he
did family who was his choice because
teal gland said he's a show of her
there's no reason to pay this um sg1
Team permanently I did like that because
that was the first time we see Teal's
characters start to develop and it took
a long time to develop tilk
um I thought family was season two
and he's got season SD one I'm not sure
I'd have to have a look in the top of
the head I think that's season two where
we meet uh rayak his son
that was season two actually yeah well
I'd have to double check I I don't I
obviously I love Stargate but I actually
can't memorize the all the episodes off
top of my head
um but anyway that's what he's bought so
we'll let him have it okay great so for
me
um season two episode 17 serpent song
was the episode that stood out for me it
was the episode where we see
um Apophis die
for the first time oh
yes it's so good so Soka as he's escaped
so car who is the demon it's so-called
one of the gold I wish we'd seen more of
we didn't say much they could have gone
so much they could have gone so many
different ways with him um I don't think
we have actually saw him get defeated
because I think Anubis defeated him it
happened off screen I think it was on
screen he we saw images of him but we
saw him like uh as a hologram I think at
one point
we didn't see it well we did see him but
um
yeah
I want to see more from him
um I like how so car attacks the SG-1
SGC with that particle Etc and starts
heating up the um Iris that I'm talking
about it was that scene from that yeah
which is something we saw later but
better technology
um but the reason why I've picked it
was apophis's death scene is genuinely
incredible and oh man I forgot that axis
name somebody in the comments down the
actor's name because he passed away oh
Peter Well Peter Williams Peter Williams
thank you
um he did such a good part fantastic he
was brilliant
the way we see
um you know that that we remember
actually there's a human side to the
gold story
and I don't think we we didn't see that
enough but that that had that had proper
impact I'm not an emotional person I
don't really cry or get upset a great
deal and I'm coming away from that
episode going oh it's bloody brilliant
wow Peter Williams of course he did the
role of the host it was like an Egyptian
uh sort of like not Passover a person
who was captured and of course he's sort
of um he's upset and of course he's got
the normal human voice rather than the
Apophis voice
um and
um great actor by Peter Williams who had
a rare chance of showing the host rather
than the gold inside him and he pulled
it off really well he think where's my
wife wears my children yeah he saw the
light and he was he was the one that
walked towards it in our it's just a
phenomenal episode yeah how about
yourself what are you picking the season
two I'm talking about the episode I like
the most from this one is the one I
introduced it to my wife and she became
a Stargate fan I remember I I had it on
VHS so this is so so long ago and it was
an episode which just really worked for
me because it was a proper sci-fi
concept and that was episode 16 a matter
of time
the episode where the gate is connected
to a black hole and there is a bad
situation arising and as it carries on
there's time distortions the
gravitational pulls it could be a
situation which destroys the world
um it to me it was just a great concept
and I always remember that first scene
where you see an sg10 or something
they're running towards the gate in slow
motion and they're looking terrified I
need to know what's going on and it just
starts to go on from there and then it
finally connects the gates it only
collects from a brief second and then
they connect back and then everything's
slowed down it was a great sci-fi
concept and um it was just one as a
standalone episode so far my choices
have been quite Standalone episodes but
I just thought that that idea was a
really great one uh yeah it was just it
was just yeah it was just my personal
favorite for some reason yeah I would
just say I made a mistake a second ago
we said that Peter Williams was dead
inside Cliff Simon that passed away no
Cliff Simon who's playing around yeah he
passed away in 2021
sorry which was um
again he was one of those actors that
um every episode he was in I could pick
was my favorite he's just particularly
in nine and ten towards the end he was
just a glorious actor
um so yeah that not good choice I like
that episode and again it was different
wasn't it sir
um our lovely subscriber for that one
picked Thor's Chariot first contact with
the Asgard oh that's the
Thor's a couple of Thor one for season
one
which is a bit of a big ass Guard ship
and then it uses like beam technology to
like yes and everything I just I love
that I was like that's such a because
nobody thinks about using that as a
weapon
just don't remember we realize beam it
up don't materialize it I thought that
was such a brilliant episode for such a
brilliant weapon
and of course it's the early days of the
Asgard and stuff of course we discover
them as they go along but I still
haven't met them at that point but we
got to see them uh yeah yeah yeah that's
right yeah
for me we're we're smacking through this
but we were a bit late so we're gonna
have to yeah sorry my fault my bad sorry
I've been having it's terrible insomnia
recently as well I got hurt my back a
couple of weeks ago and ever since I
can't sleep
but at some point at 10 o'clock I'm just
gonna go
[Laughter]
I'm sure we could get through this
before 10 o'clock that shouldn't be a
problem so what was your choice for
season three what was your choice series
three episode 16 ergo
because oh it was one of the first
properly hilarious episodes
from Cannonball Run yeah and of course
his son is a director Peter DeLuise
Peter DeLuise was the activist yeah I
know all about themes yeah yeah the
whole de Luis family there's a whole
boring not you
well there's a whole DeLuise
um storyline that goes through the whole
thing there's like Peter de Luis was in
it um his two of his brothers were Peter
DeLuise met his wife
yeah and um
I believe
um and Dom deluise's other son played
the love interest for cartoon about
season eight or something as well yeah
he was the cop wasn't he yep yep
The Other Brother played the lead guy
Wormhole extreme wormhole
the
little fact about Ergo that I absolutely
adore about is that Christopher Judge
while they were doing all the building
up to it went to the writers and asked
to be written out of the episode as much
as possible and they agreed
because he couldn't keep his bloody face
straight
he kept laughing and he just couldn't
stop Dom DeLuise just cracked him up all
the way through so he just said look I
can't do it just keep me out of it as
much as I can please and and I just love
that fact from it I just I can just
because now we know Christopher Judge a
bit more you know in interviews and
stuff oh he's got a great sense of humor
isn't he he's always he could just go if
you see
the behind the scenes he's always
laughing and he's always you could tell
that they had a great chemistry at the
actual cast They had a good laugh doing
it yeah yeah so I look at that now and I
think yeah 100 Christopher George was
pissing himself all the way through that
um I completely believe that
uh I I think it's going to be the big
one for season three and it's gonna be
Nemesis I mean my God the first time we
see the replicators
um I love the way that they first came
along that purple spiders
music coming along on the uh on the
Asgard ship with Thor
um and they were
at the time they they struck me as being
like the Borg of Stargate because there
was something completely different and
something very potentially dangerous we
which we haven't seen in series at that
point
um and it was just a very very solid we
had a great uh uh story with Thor and
Jack stuck on the ship the ship is you
know gonna be crashing into the planet
and they're gonna all sorts of things
going on
um and um it was just very solid and of
course the
the replica case um stayed around for
the remainder of the series even beyond
that
um and I just thought for me it was just
such a great introduction for
potentially the real big baddies after
the the gold in season three that's
that's my perspective and I mean they
were so good I mean they and they I
don't think I liked about the
replicators as well they evolved in such
an intelligent like
a way that you let go well of course
they would evolve that way this
completely makes sense and the other
thing I didn't like was when we sort of
saw a version of the replicators in the
Atlantis episodes I thought that was a
bit sort of tacked on a bit but um but
even that was yeah well they were
different they weren't like they weren't
like the out the uh our sort of Galaxy
replicators they were the same name but
it didn't have anything in in much in
common with them in many ways so I I was
never a such a fan of the Atlantis
replicators
warships I thought that start that
storyline was a bit odd for me
um uh amazing subscriber picked the
devil you know
um
I don't remember the episode off top of
my head
I think he's a villain
the devil you know
it wasn't demons because that was also
the same season oh no yeah oh that was
the um the socar you it now pop is
reveal himself he promises to the
prisoners to overturned it was part two
of uh
cargo ship and go in and everything down
there yeah yeah and it was part two of a
two-part story it was all right I didn't
mind it
um and of course that was the episode
where Apophis uh reveals that he's still
alive and he's got this kind of like um
metal on his face and everything and he
yeah
the computer game Mortal Kombat has got
one of them I can't remember which one
it is rape racking or something reminded
me enough it was that dude from Mortal
Kombat
um yeah
series four right series four go on Me
episode one
straight off the replicators like you
said okay yeah yeah
what do you like about it what was it
there are certain episodes that when I
watched it first time around like like
you know
um politics for me in series one that
when I watched it
um I
I just remember thinking God damn this
is good show and that this was the first
episode I remember thinking I think I
prefer this to Star Trek
always attractive always a tracking
um just just what I think Mark has sent
it hassano on there and the company is
called Brew yeah blue bricks that have
got the rights to produce some Lego
models or Lego esque models for of
Stargate they do a lot of Star Trek ones
um I've already made contact with them
and we will be getting some exclusive
um conversations with blue bricks
hopefully about the development of the
episodes and we might even be able to
get our hands maybe on an early set to
give away fingers crossed but um
already they're a big German company
um and they do lots of military Lego
sets and things but yeah they've got the
Stargate
um but yeah so I loved this episode
because I was about the Russian
submarine the Russians got involved for
the first time with the Stargate I just
thought again it was just such a good
episode I love how at the end of the
episode The replicator comes back up on
top of the thing oh no they're not dead
and I just I love the um that Sam goes
off with the Asgard and they go well we
wouldn't have thought of throwing lead
projectiles it's them so we need maybe a
stupid way of looking at this and sounds
like a stupid way yeah stupid
perspective I thought was really funny
and then I love when they get there and
there's the O'Neill and it's our most
advanced Starship ever built into the
O'Neill I'm just going yeah and they
have to destroy it as well yeah
that's really clever yeah Jack has a
little joke at the end like you
destroyed it
it's just great yeah and it's but this
is honestly that first episode where
I've just sort of realized
I'm a gator
I'm not attracting anymore
I think really season four the beginning
of those two parties season three and
four that's when Stargate really became
one of the big league shows yeah
um it it kind of got to the point where
look this is kind of like on the Star
Trek level of quality writing and
visuals and acting and everything else
and that's that to me was when it got to
that plateau and then they never looked
back after that and I think that's
probably what you and I might have got
that Vibe when we watched that two
Pastor Nemesis and that one so yeah yeah
this is yes it was it was a new level it
was a new level and I think that's when
we realized and I never never changed my
mind from that point almost right to
today so there we go we're amazing
subscriber agrees with me by the way
that small victories is the best episode
of That season
what did you pick well um one aspect
I've said before is I love the comedic
side of things in the show
um and again it's this is another
Standalone episode but I'm a big fan of
of Bill Murray I'm a big fan of
Groundhog Day so of course I'm going to
choose window of opportunity the time
loot episode where O'Neill and tilk end
up every episode every hour or whatever
it is eating fruit loops eating cereal
and it just goes round and round around
and they have to solve this problem it's
been done to death in many sci-fi shows
but I just thought there's a lot of
Comedy
um you know an eel playing golf knocking
the ball through the Stargate and
um that's going to be some kind of
record
the ball
um it was just it has worked for me
because it showed how it could have
great big storylines it could have great
big characters but great big threats but
it can also just have an episode which
is just funny but laugh out loud funny
yeah yeah
sometimes tried to be funny but they
were laugh out loud hilarious
um I'm sorry but the bit where O'Neill
brings in and gives George his
resignation and Adam
sounds like sure why so I can do this
and he goes He swings down and kisses
Carter and then it goes yeah and it's
back to him eating the cereal again
brilliant and um and teal getting
smacked in the face with the door each
time and just thinks again and again and
eventually he hits it back or something
doesn't he push it down the stairs I
think
and then um learning to juggle and
things like this I just I just I adore
that episode
um it's It's the funniest
Scythe I I think he might be one of the
funniest episodes the entire Stargate uh
franchise I think he might be right up
there personally it's um it's got so
many brilliant moments in it I think
when people as soon as you say that
episodes to people they go oh God damn
it that's a good episode you know they
just do it's just fantastic
my my pick for Series 17 and I'm sorry
whoa okay it was that popular
um
so
um the reason I love this episode was we
found out later this was anubis's plan
and it was a deal with um the goal
system Lords but basically the lob an
asteroid at Earth and it's going to wipe
out all right this is a good episode
yeah I like how they're on the
spacesuits they use they think you know
they get that um the transport ship and
then they end up um doing a hyperspace
jump say jump the asteroids through the
other side yeah because they realize
it's in the quadrian asteroids it's too
heavy sort of thing and all that I just
I think the reason why I love this
episode so much is
whenever I think about those key
episodes this is one that jumps into me
because again
it was just so different but it was
different to Stargate that was the thing
one reason why I love Stargate so much
it kept reimagining itself and this
episode did that again it reimagined
itself and did something a bit different
and
um and the thing is more often than not
it worked
and
my lovely subscriber agrees with me
again
that's it that's good
all right by yourself what did you pick
uh I have to say with this season
um because I think the fifth season it
had some weaker episodes my personal
favorite I liked 48 hours I almost
nominated that but in the end I'm gonna
go for 2001.
um it was a fascinating episode a
what-if kind of thing where
um it was
um yeah actually was it 2001 2010 was
too oh yeah
actually I thought it would be around I
thought 2010
where was the one where they're in the
future there to go back oh no you're
right it's 2000 2001 anyway what's the
episode when they make uh
no but there was one
yeah the 2000 2001 was the one where
they make contact with Shen and they're
aware that the future
sorry can you hear me right all right so
it was the episode where
there was a
literally a really
really trying to avoid it and um there
were links to the other episode 2010
which was set in the future where um it
all went very very bad so it was a great
link to that where anneal in 2010 throws
the the note through the Stargate to say
don't do not contact this world you know
that's awesome he doesn't does he
because he dies on the steps of the gate
yeah she does but it goes through and
then they have to avert the future so I
just thought that was quite a solid
story in respect of uh what ifs kind of
thing so um and it's kind of what Brad
Wright has been talking about that he
wants the new series to look like well
the world with you saying where it's the
Stargate is known to everybody the
Stargate was in what looked like the
middle of a supermarket yes or an
airport sink
division that Brad Wright did have for
the new Stargate if he'd have got it
which he didn't
um yeah I I would have liked to finish
end more I I would like to use I would
like us to revisit this year when we get
the new series
which I'm I'm not even going to say if
we get the new series anymore when we
get the new series
um I'd like I'd love us to revisit this
show
did I hear that
I heard that at some point they were
really considering making a third Shin
story needed to work out when they made
the original sg1 ages ago they did
originally have an idea of bringing
their Shen back for a third story and it
never happened
like I said if we can see them again
I think it was atlanticism
I think so
um because Joseph malozi Club but I
might be wrong
I do occasionally make things it was a
good story I like both the Ascend story
lines the 2001 and 2010 I thought they
were both very solid
um so yeah that's my my vote for season
five how about your subscriber what have
what have they voted for for season five
uh no he agreed with me so um yeah he
went for fail safe as well so oh no
where am I lying
no threshold you went for threshold so
um oh yeah yeah okay threshold yeah
season six episode 22 full circle
um
is
again it's that episode that I can
remember exactly where I was sat in the
house that I owned at the time when I
watched this episode and
um it was back when I had to watch this
on sky and we had to record it but you
have to record it when it was like oh
yeah yeah I immediately sat there and
the wife went can I put what we watching
that again
just watched it again immediately and
she wasn't very assuming but oh the
Stargate team would return to abados and
we see it was a full circle it was a
with a mascara
turns up in his big Mothership which I
adored I thought that was such a good
and he's after the Eye of Ra which is
the core to his super weapon
um and then obviously we we see him
destroy
um abados and then we see the um and the
actual pyramid
yeah yeah it was really epic really epic
I also love that there's an awesome
scene where Daniel keeps appearing in
front of
um Anubis and telling him you're not
going to do it and they said and I know
he was like you can't stop me and then
he does that thing where you start off
and then the and the um and you've seen
God no no and then pull him away it's
one of those great scenes that just work
so well
um and then obviously we got Daniel back
a little and uh the next episode I think
um and we got to see the tablet with the
lost city so this is when we introduced
Atlantis as well yes it was the first
first um link towards the next the first
spin-off absolutely so it's just such an
important episode but they knew it was
such an important episode and they
banged it out the park it's one of those
episodes Absolutely
nailed it brilliant episode
it's one of the best episodes of any
season
yeah it's in putting the top 10 best uh
episodes of the entire show probably so
absolutely
um for me I also have an episode which
features Daniel
um but not this episode but it also uh
brings a very important character which
of course um we've already talked about
and that is uh I can't think of the
number it's
um
Abyss
yep so where we first meet
um ball and um we see Daniel uh
appearing to Jack and obviously Jack is
uh in a bad situation he's been tortured
by Bal
um and I just thought it was a very
solid episode first of all ball straight
first time this is the first time I
think we've seen him and I think it's
the first time you might have seen the
season five actually
in I think actually wait it's one of the
first appearances anyway uh I think this
is second actually
um And he as a protagonist he he comes
across as a very very dangerous and
somebody don't want to mess about with
and he's got
um O'Neill and he wants to get this
information off here please will keeps
killing him over and over again yeah and
then he's got like he's got his like
arrows and things and he sort of like
it's got a gravitational pull and he
sort of like and he pours acid onto it
and all sorts of things and he's trying
to break him and of course um yeah I
just thought it was a very solid episode
but yeah I think that was bal's Second
Story it was in the two-part in season
five but even so I just like that a
particular episode it just stood out for
me yeah uh amazing subscriber picked
descent in that episode that's um that's
a good one yeah that's the one with the
pyramid ship under the water that was a
good episode as well yeah
and then colorim and the Jaffa assassins
and all that wasn't it yeah yeah
um Anubis uh yeah all they're sort of
like uh Jafar and stuff so yeah that was
a good one as well
episode
um of series seven for me I it's one of
those double episodes so it's both
really but
um evolution
um
I loved that episode because I mean it
was all over the place the SG team ended
up splitting up there
um but it's the first time we see the
anubis's um super soldiers
um yeah we love any episode of Bray
attacking and basically any excuse to
mention oh great attack is so good yeah
um yeah I just think the man is an
absolute Legend he's absolutely
brilliant
um they were looking for the Fountain of
Youth I love this thing about how they
were talking about the the very first
apocophagus was based on this ancient
technology that's been lost it reminded
Daniel of this story about his Grandad
to say about the Fountain of Youth
so they went looking for the the
technology
um I'd love those episodes when we get
to see a little bit more
um of the background sort of thing um
without it being a flashback or
something because I hate flashback
episodes but so we got we got they're
just layered Pages onto the story of the
gold and the Ancients how the gold were
these parasites you know technologically
as well as
you know physically
um living off other people's
Technologies and stuff I just thought it
was just such a clever episode but also
it was so well written
in that
[Music]
um
it was it was it was a proper dramatic
episode it went all over the place I say
the story was a proper roller coaster it
was just a great episode it's a
brilliant double episode
I thought that was a good one
um for me I think it's the season finale
to pass the lost city
um because it was first of all it's the
first time we meet Dr Weir although it's
a different actress who plays Dr Weir uh
and it sets up all the beginnings of the
links to Atlantis which of course is so
done so well when that series started uh
it has some pretty epic moments in it um
I like the fact that the president is is
kind of like um advice well actually at
this point he'd already been advice from
the from the clip show beforehand but
then they have to sort of like um like
Hammond is re-assigned and um yeah it
was just a good solid episode I just I
just like the whole setup for Atlantis
and in the end um you know Anil has to
have the portal thing again the the
Oracle of memory and he starts to do
what he did before where he starts to
speak ancient language
um
he builds anti-replicator weapon isn't
it that's it yeah that's it that's it
that's what it was
um and I just thought it was a very
solid episode and it's
put into stasis you wonder what's going
to happen
um and it was it was just very well done
so I think that's um yeah yeah although
I will give an honorable mention to
Avenger uh 2.0 because that was the
doctor felger appears I I like Dr philjo
the the nerdy guy who's um always
looking up to the the Stargate team I
did like that one but it's not them yeah
it's not the top one but it's up there
as well
um uh amazing subscriber picked
inauguration so the episode we mentioned
before we talked about Filler episodes
nobody did better than the Stargate and
that episode pretty fair when the new
president yeah they did the best they
did the best
great episode very clever very funny as
right again another one is funny and and
you've got to feel for the president in
that situation I'll come with an actor's
name but I love the actor as well he's
done loads of things over the years
really active but um you just sit down
it's your first day in a new job and
somebody goes right we've got to tell
you all this stuff because no no I've
been briefed
no you are but it gets much worse
um so no I love her so it's very clever
episode again
um series eight for me episode 15 we're
talking about Filler episodes it is
citizen Joe
um I love that episode but the the main
reason I loved it because it was clever
I loved extra thing the main reason I
loved it though was because when they
all look at Jack at the end and they
sort of Go sir so have you been seeing
bits of his life and he said yeah and
you didn't mention it no quite relaxing
I just
and you just think because yeah that's
Jack
I just thought it's a great episode
again very clever very funny
um again it was a filler episode in lots
of ways but it was a filler episode that
was just done so brilliantly
um
it's a Charming episode
absolutely I thought it was funny
um for me it was the two-parter Mobius
um time travel episode in the season
where um they had to go back to ancient
Egypt and they they want to get a
um what are those power devices can't
think of what they're called cpms see
that's it you have to get one of those
um and I just thought it was a very
solid episode I like the fact that um we
see another alternate kind of universe a
sort of more sort of nerdy uh Carter and
uh I mean they did this quite a few
times we saw alternate realities
with short hair
yeah
it was just funny in the way that
almost like an Sgt
and they all came together
to to solve the problem and it was just
a really nice end of season thing as
well so um I even had Rodney McKay
appear in it as well and I just thought
that was a great team because I gotta
say I actually think
um series six seven and eight that we've
just gone through obviously those are
the three series I really struggled with
picking but it's like yeah you know if
you're like a football manager and
you've got like 20 brilliant players and
it's a really hard decision to pick 11.
that was that was one of those decisions
it was a tough to pick one because these
three seasons
every episode I'm thinking oh man that
was a good episode oh that was but
that's the first time they did this it's
really hard it's really really good but
I'm bringing that up really because
season nine
was difficult for a difference okay so
what was it difficult for you it's
possibly the weakest season of Stargate
for me I actually loved the aurai story
lines a lot of people don't like them I
like the all right I don't have probably
all right I thought they were I thought
they were brilliant but I thought the
last season was better than the first
season I think about this season ended
right and I I actually picked the final
episode um Camelot
even though it had bits in it I didn't
love I didn't love them having to do the
sword fight with the with the you know
with the Black Knight and stuff but we
have the super gate we had all of that
um
and I just thought it was it's great but
the main reason why I love it is I am a
sucker for a space battle you give me a
Spaceball me too me
happy
um when the four RI ships come through
and do some batter everybody it's just
it's just great
um in season 20 so again some of the
Space Battles
loved it I love the little you know
little
um the deadless flying in and out around
that's what she says oh just great but
yeah um it's not the strongest season
um but
a very cool finale
yeah
um I went for an episode which actually
I think it potentially almost featured
the first supergate although it didn't
work in the end and that was episode six
beachhead where we had the prior who
ends up on a gate
he starts to put this energy on the
start again it's sort of expands or
something and it it it it was just where
yeah there was a shield over there who
say
yeah and the other Jafar is sort of like
it probably comes along and he says that
we are free we do not believe in false
gods and of course by the end of it it's
it's turning to a sort of a big
situation where you know in the end
you're working out that they're trying
to make a super gay and they do this by
collapsing on the uh a planet or
something it's been a while since I saw
it but um I just thought that was that's
the one that stood out for me and it
just showed me how bad the uh priors can
potentially be and the RAR so that's why
that was when we first started the Jaffa
being the Free Nation moving towards
that whole storyline with actually the
Jaffa then start to believe the aura are
actually God's yes
and I I remember the um
the top thing I know is oh his name's
gonna damn it he's the leader of the
free Jafar a great actor he was in that
boxing film with him
I do know his name but anyway
um he's brilliant yeah I know the actor
yeah
um it's just it's just a thing because
he's saying he did this whole monologue
saying well but they're not gods and and
then the leaders are jumping on well
they're energy beings that can do almost
anything and they can control matter
what what is a God then if that's not a
god
and they say this these are Godly you
know Lou Gossett Jr thank you Chief
that's it
yeah that's it that's in film we've got
to Junior did with James Woods is
generally one of those films that I've
got I've got a handful of films that I
can watch anytime I can sit and watch
anytime
um and it's going to annoy me because I
can't remember what it's called but um
it's that that's actually Gene Hackman
um this film I say with James Woods
um and and like a handful of others it's
just it's just a brilliant movie he has
to he has to fight I said like 10 fights
in a night and then this guy and it's
like a bet and they're trying to it's a
con game and Luke Goss the junior is
getting battered in the end because the
guy's bringing a couple of them ringers
and stuff it's a great film
um somebody in the comments will Google
it and tell me what it's called because
it's gonna kill me as soon as I remember
it but grateful
um oh so our amazing subscriber did pick
after returns in a minor gold as a feast
and we can hope and pray for our returns
he forgot to put the name of the episode
so we won't worry about it so all right
okay episode 20 season 20.
has forgotten to put the name of this
episode again so I don't have to worry
about that but um I think I know what
he's on about but
um so for me
you've got to go with the final episode
how many series
star Sci-Fi series now can you honestly
hand on heart say had a good final
episode
for me it's not many some do but it tend
to be not as good well no I mean some of
the Star Treks series are pretty good
some are a bit you know
um
it's not very good voyages episode is
brilliant into deep space nines episode
final episode was not very good
um Enterprise yeah Enterprises was a bit
the first part was okay but the second
part was
um deep space nines the good episode the
final episode was like three episodes
from the end and then they had the old
parade thing at the end I was like oh
I've got a sport
um but stargate's finale episode was
genuinely
brilliant and not just because it gave
us a really nice storyline with them
with the aura and we lost the Asgard and
then the aura were chasing because they
could track the
um Asgard core
um so they had to create that time
bubble we then got to see a really nice
sort of finale for a lot of these
characters we got to see Daniel and
Viola come together
we got to see a nice thing with tealc
um it's just it was so it had a bit of
everything you know it had it had a bit
of Hume it had a bit of fence and it had
a bit of drama and a problem to solve
and it had a little bit of character and
it was just it felt like a nice goodbye
to a series that had managed 10 years
and it didn't
Enterprises final episode was a massive
disappointment when it should have been
an easy one for me it was rushed that
was that's what it was so they didn't
know they were going to cancel until
yeah that's why that's Russia we said
why it wasn't as good as it could have
been but um Stargate
they they really were able to take their
time with an ending and create an
episode that deserved
what it got
um SGA had again exactly yeah SGA 100
Mac the sga's finale was actually really
good as well
um
again that felt like a nice goodbye but
it was action-packed way more
action-packed than sg1's finale but
um I just wish we've got a bit more
let's open the new series comes back we
can get a bit more but um but yeah
unending for me brilliant episode and a
great finale
all right
I have to agree it's unending for me
it's the end the series finale
um
every other one's a bit different but uh
I know you could go wrong with that I
mean it was just so
solid
um you know where I love the idea that
they're in a situation where they've
literally got to live the rest of their
lives on a ship and they've got nothing
to do and they work out a way eventually
to get out of the problem but they're
aging and Daniel sort of forms
relationship with Vala and and it was
just
I don't know it just it is because it
was not like what I would have thought I
would have thought it'd be the last time
we actually don't I think we only just
briefly see the Stargate itself in the
very last scene of the episode
um because they're about to go out again
aren't they
that's it and that was it
um but I I just like the idea
of um a situation where and I just love
the way you got the energy about to hit
the ship and then it like it jumps like
10 years ahead you see that the the bolt
is slightly closer to the ship where in
real time it's
really old yeah
um I I it was just very it was just very
well done it was almost like a bottle
show because there were just mainly just
on the ship using these the same sets
but however they did it whoever the
roads it or thought it up they actually
did something for me which just really
stood out it was just a very solid end
to a such a great series after 10 years
which not many shows get to that length
and um yeah
but sci-fi shows never do 10 years I
think there's only X-Files and
Supernatural that have done it X-Files
is one X-Files Supernatural eleven
impossible
um there's not many it's a handful of
series that have ever done ten and oh
somebody will always go Doctor Who
Doctor Who has not had consecutive I was
gonna mention that yeah that's
not two is like it's it's it keeps
Reinventing itself it's not like the
same act as the whole way through and
the majority of the Stargate actors were
there until the end so it's not quite
the same
um yeah but really good
that is our pick then we have the tent I
will I will put the list up and I'll put
us a um a a put it on the Community page
bit later and I'll ask people to tell us
where we're right and where we're wrong
but that is our pick for the best 10
episodes but before I let you go Mike
and before I go to bed
it's 10 o'clock it's still on
it's dead in 10 o'clock
um I'd love to know your opinion on
obviously we've had lots of ups and
downs again with the Stargate new series
movie rumors so um I don't know how much
you've kept up with my videos recently
but I have seen some of the videos I
have seen some not all of them but I've
seen obviously you watch all of my
videos and you love it
of course so the news was a couple of
weeks ago that actually the head of
Amazon movies Jennifer salkey has said
yes we're going to do a movie dammit I
don't care what the rest of you think
we're doing a movie and she's put this
um
document basically authorizing the head
of film
um Courtney Valentini to begin the
development work I've now heard
since that a few people Michael Wright
and a few of the other Executives and
other people that have actually said
look we want to do a series not a bloody
movie uh kicking up a bit of a fuss
they've done an internal
um survey and about 80 of people that
they said they'd come back and said we
would like a series not a movie
I just wondered if you have to know what
what do you think where would you go
movie or I I completely agree with the
idea of a proper series uh like a 10
episode season
um I I mean I I'm like you at this point
I just want anything which is brand new
well quality made Stargate
um if we get a movie that'd be great but
to have a proper 10 season 10 episode
season
um with
um a continuation of the SG-1 series not
a reboot it all reboots
um it's a good example is the start of
Picard which in many ways season three
is like season eight of TNG it's not
perfect but it's a continuation a lot of
the story arcs a lot of the story lines
have come back and it's just flourished
it's just what we've all been wanting as
a Stargate and I want that as well I
want to even if a lot of the actors
aren't available they could they could
anyone it's all sorts of story arcs and
story lines from the sg1 series you can
even have crossovers with Atlantis even
in the universe so I'm very hopeful that
they go that route we don't get a reboot
if we get a TV or we get a movie that'd
be interesting but I personally
um think that Stargate really works
better in a TV format than compared to a
movie format I know it originated from a
movie format but sg1 completely changed
what Stargate was based on what it
created over those 10 seasons
um that's my thoughts and hopes and yeah
I I did see one of your recent um uh
shows where you were saying that
basically you were fearful that if
there's all this infighting about what
you know one person wants to do the
movie one person wants to do the TV show
it is enough disagreement it could all
potentially fall through and it might
not happen they might think this is more
all trouble that's worth stuff it let's
just let's do it so that that's a worry
but I'm hopeful that Stargate is a big
enough property of MGM that something
will be creating hopefully a TV
continuation of some sort That's My Hope
yeah I think the only way I want to and
then they are talking about cinematic
release if they did a cinematic release
and they've got Richard Dean Anderson to
come back as O'Neill and we got Sam
because I don't think Richard leave that
someone's come back for a series but he
might be talking yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and then there was apparently the
idea that actually JJ Abrams and think
he had was that they were going to kill
O'Neill off
that he was going to actually save the
day but he was going to have to
sacrifice himself in the process and he
would be killed now I don't want to see
Jack O'Neill killed actually Matthew I
do videos with live videos with he he
hates this idea but I'm telling you what
man if Richard Dean Anthony wants to
come back and do one movie and he
doesn't want to do the series he'll do a
movie and they they ended O'Neill
character in a big dramatic way like
that I'd be okay with it I know yeah
yeah yeah you get to say goodbye and
then that is a gateway a two-hour advert
for this Catalyst then for something
else afterwards if it was successful
but my fear is if it's not successful
that could kill the franchise before it
even starts that's my own Affair so
you're saying it's more
of a mission that they went through
rather than potentially a TV season
yeah I think so because
if people don't go for it well look at
Picard season three no it's brilliant we
all love it it could not get into the
top ten the first five weeks it was in
and now
because it found its audience yeah a
Series has got chance if enough people
watch it enough people talk about it we
all go on YouTube and we share it's
bloody brilliant watch it I know that's
how they does something it's advertising
they're advertising to show you exactly
it can find its audience though a movie
if people don't go to the cinema
it's very difficult to do that because
you've basically got three or four weeks
it's quite rare for a movie if it
doesn't do well their first week that it
does better very very touch and go very
very good yeah so I I'd be worried about
a movie just from that point of view
um I think if they did a first season
and then did a movie I think it would be
more but apparently the idea has always
been that they want to do this as a
franchise which would be movies TV
series games and they want this they
genuinely think this will be their big
sci-fi project and if they're gonna do
that
I think it's got to start with a
cinematic movie
so I can kind of see what Jennifer
salkey is coming from She's swinging for
the fences a little bit but well let me
just quickly say this myself and my
colleague Martin on my podcast we've
been saying for literally for two or
three years how Star Trek has come back
Star Wars has come back where Stargate
there is a I know that it's maybe not as
big as the Star Trek and stuff
especially not Star Wars um franchises
but it is Big it's got a big audience
and
uh I'm just we're we are both surprised
that it's not already come back you know
I I would have thought that with MGM I
know there's been a lot of things going
on with with all sorts of finances and
stuff but I'm surprised it's not already
back it is such a special show it's it's
one of mgm's biggest ever
um Commodities uh after
um James Bond which in its own right
makes it very likely that it should have
all these potential ideas of a a you
know spin-offs and you know all sorts of
things so again so I would really hope
that it does happen
um but like and it's the uncertainty
Factor we don't know I mean we could be
in a year's time you might be inviting
back in a year's time or whatever and
they're like we'll say well look do you
remember what we said about this and
look how it went and you know it all
went wrong or it could be saying it
could be like a film on the way a TV
series there could be you know all sorts
of things it's different now it's
different from back in the day we'd have
like one show but on these streaming
sites you often have like a whole Hub of
TV shows they like they want to pull you
into that with all these different
things like the MGM and and the Star
Wars on on the Disney
um sort of thing so
um I don't know it's interesting I I I'm
I'm cautiously optimistic but I don't
know I I think there's room for it and
but if they do do it again will they
mess it up will they do a startup
discovery
or will they make it
touch would spin around three times we
don't mention Star Trek Discovery when
talking about cargo just in case
um yeah yeah it's no that's terrifying
um no I
yeah I I would like to think they've
looked at Star Trek and learned the
lessons that this the mistake Star Trek
made if they're looking at the if
they're looking at Discovery and going
well let's do let's make it dark and
let's do this let's do that we can
change loads of things right people
won't get upset will they then they're
they're freaking idiots and they deserve
us to go and Riot and knock down their
buildings and which I'm not saying we
should because I'll get my you're not
condoning it I'm not condoning violence
but I'm saying I'll be in the front
leaving the path
um but you know it's just like this show
deserves better and I think it's can and
to be honest if they mess it up they're
idiots because it's easy
it's so easy to do the show and bring it
back
so easy
um all they've got to do is keep it nice
and simple but they've got if Mark
Fergus doesn't get put off by all of
this infighting all this confusion if
they keep Mark Ferguson board he is the
man to do this
right why couldn't Brad Wright still be
involved even if there's like because he
was the person who pitched the idea
and it was falling through but he knows
Stargate surely get people in this new
series even if it's like a
um create a consultant or something to
actually have an input for the fans who
will recognize that quality I'd like to
think they would get involved and at
least get him in to do something the
main reason why I can't show One is
because he doesn't own a production
company and they've got to get a
production company on board to do it and
then they will need to get if we believe
the current rumors this is why Bad Robot
are involved it's not really because of
Bad Robot it's because of Warner
Brothers
want to make the film
for MGM which the relationship they've
already had for a while now the Creed
Trilogy I'm just talking about is Warner
Brothers there's a few other films MGM
have done in cooperation with Warner
Brothers
and Amazon Warner Brothers are looking
at Amazon thinking that's a cash cow
that's what seems to be the thing
I have heard a more recent rumor
apparently that actually there's there's
possibility of a big deal between Amazon
and Warner Brothers to rent Studio space
because
um Amazon don't have any oh
um so that would be and that this could
be part of okay
um possibly
um right so if that works out then
that's it I think that's another reason
why possibly they're looking at a
cinematic movies again because they want
it to be part of this deal with Warner
Brothers to produce
um if that's the case though let me ask
you a question
sorry I was just going to say I mean
do you think though that I mean
basically Stargate originally started as
a movie which then created a TV series
if they did go with the movie Roots
could there be like a repetition of the
original Stargate where it was quite it
was relatively successful movie and then
it became its own independent TV show do
you think they might think about
replicating that idea and sort of trying
again the second time around or
I suppose I don't know I don't think
they will in a way because I think
whatever they end up doing will be
integrated together because if they've
got any sense they'll do what Marvel did
and and that was what I was told God
bloody nearly two years ago now when I
first had this conversation that's what
they were looking at they were looking
Amazon were looking at what Marvel have
done
with this integrated University but
because it's cheaper to do
what you do is you have actors that work
on the TV series in the movies and you
have a couple of sound stages that are
constantly working on projects so you
could literally have a movie filming
next door to two Series going on and
that they're all influencers and the
actors could literally you can have a
guest star in the series really easily
because you just has to walk across the
road one day and he can appear in the
series
and you can share sets you can share
special effects and all this sort of
thing it's it's it's a little bit
cheaper
to do it that way but also you get a
better end product because you could
really suck people in because you
actually have them the movie actors in
the series in the series is in the movie
and and it's just really really easy to
do
um if they if so if they do that
I actually think if we get the movie it
will it will be really it will lead into
a series really easily right but then
the series will then lead back into the
next movie and and vice versa they're
not worried about them being separated
like they used to be
they they really can integrate these
things but
I'm also curious about how much
financially they would actually throw
into it I mean if they did a movie would
they would it be a quite a big
Blockbuster movie or would they try and
sort of take the the relatively good
quality movie but really save on the
pennies and what I'm hearing is that
they want to keep it reasonably low
budget
um but I mean that's a reasonably low
budget for Amazon don't forget but um I
I I was told we're not looking at 100
million it'd be less than 100 million
for production but the last Batgirl
movie was 80 million and we knew how
much that was we don't always know what
the production
actually how much it costs to make the
film sort of thing yeah but if we get
something on 100 million but and that
all that means though is they won't get
big A-list actors in it which we don't
necessarily want anyway doesn't that no
it doesn't have to be that I mean I
don't need Will Smith earning 30 million
quid thank you
just bring us some good actors
um yeah I think people like Michael
Shanks and Samantha Carter will do this
for a packet of crisps in a bourbon
biscuit so I don't think they'll have to
pay him a great deal
um
it's you know it's like so getting
getting these actors that that we love
anyway and just get good
character actors
um and then um but I'm hearing that
because
um what I was told was that there's
there was a fear that it won't be
massively successful
um or what they're doing they're setting
the budget to their expectations
so this doesn't have to be number one
for 20 weeks in the cinemas uh for them
to go on to do a franchise if it goes in
at number one and they get and they at
least make their money back and they get
an okay return they're happy to then
that that's a success for them because
they can the way I was I was told is the
plan is to make this a two-hour advert
for the rest of the franchise
all right that's the way they're coming
at it they don't expect this to be the
biggest movie in history they just need
it to kick off the franchise it's it's
yeah it's like the beginning of a new
sort of chapter kind of thing
you know
um if that's the case I think that's
quite that's quite sensible I'm shocked
because it's actually quite sensible
um
the one fear I have is that it took
about four years for Star Trek to
finally sort itself out and we're
finally getting there now and I'm just
worried after I think Stargate finished
in 2011 with the universe or something
like that so it's been quite a long time
I'm worried that the people that make
the news Target if and when it happens
will get Stargate
because it's only the people who really
run it and like the fans who know what
Stargate is to appreciate it you get
people to come in
and they haven't got a clue they make
their interpretation of what they think
Stargate is and sometimes that is lost
in transit something is lost and then
alienates the fans again if we get Mark
Fergus um I heard from one of my sources
that they were um that Mark Craig was
sitting in a meeting and they were
pitching and throwing a few ideas around
and one of the ideas was
um they wanted to bring Robert Carlisle
back because they've done some sort of
um survey or something right and Robert
Carlisle was the second name after
Richard Dean Anderson who is somehow
would have the most impact if he
returned I don't know how they pitched
that survey I don't God knows how his
name got so hard
and so they started talking about and
said well could we do something with SGU
Mark and Mark apparently then talked
about the planet Builders and how he
wanted the third season of Stargate
Universe to go for nearly an hour
and he just basically talked at the
executives for an hour and he wasn't he
did not he didn't know they were going
to say that yeah
asked for Stargate he loves Stargate it
seems and he seems to know it backwards
about the planet builders for an hour
but isn't this to you the least uh
popular Stargate Series in the franchise
yeah but I mean my point is though that
they just mentioned that and Paul and
asked him about it and he knew it off
top of his head
so I mean
if he knows SGU he's going to know the
rest
I mean that just really impressed me
that he knew that off top of his head
but I'll tell you what though um
whenever we talk to people about what
what sort of movies you'll see and I do
polls on the channel
SGU always does really well
yes I I liked it myself it's just when
it was on it was different and it was
very influenced by Battlestar Galactica
that was the one thing which I had to
kind of adjust to but by the end of the
second season I was really enjoying it
so you know but I think people the
people that want like the show though
want a conclusion to it and that's the
thing absolutely I mean who doesn't want
a conclusion yeah yeah and there's some
big questions we're asked in that series
that we want big answers to so book
um
Steve has just asked me what's the best
Stargate series to watch
Adidas poll actually literally a couple
of days ago which is what is the best
Stargate Series in SG-1 want ran by mile
weirdly Infinity the cartoon they did
and um Stargate Origins got absolutely
no votes none
I got over 1800 votes I'll very quickly
have a look at it go for it
um so
um let's have a look
roll down okay what is the best Stargate
series 2.4
000 votes to 2 400 votes sg1 got 70 SGA
got 15 SGU got 14 sgr Insurance got none
and SG Infinity got none episode
nobody liked the cartoon
I've never seen the cartoon I've seen
Origins it felt like a very it felt a
bit more like a fan of Film Production
it didn't feel like a proper Stargate
but I didn't I think it was interesting
to watch
um
I mean I didn't I didn't love it but I
didn't loathe it either it was all right
and it had um in it as well didn't it
from Star Star Trek was in it
um but I was interesting that your vote
with the universe and Atlantis was very
very close
like you know because I I thought
lattice was higher than universe so
that's that's good to know actually I'm
glad that universities appreciated
yeah it was good though right so let's
call it an evening because it's nearly
20 past 10.
um Mike I'd love you to join us next
week because I'd love to do a Star Trek
video if you if you are free and if we
can get your Internet working uh I'd
love to uh I will get my internet better
next time I will reset my Hub I promise
you so I'm sorry
because we're getting into the last
couple of episodes of Star Trek by then
Picard
um and we'll really we should know a bit
more about what's going on but I think
it'll be a really nice way of
getting ourselves geared up for the
finale and then I think you wanted to do
a video on your podcast for them
yeah you're Frozen but you're pulling a
lovely face so don't worry about it
um
when part ends is that right I think
yeah it's uh it's three more weeks I
think until it finishes so it's it's
nearly there but um is it three or four
that's four more weeks
yeah it's four episodes rather so yeah
um I'm sure I can um be uh free to do
something with you guys or just yourself
that'd be great so yeah coming on board
to be on board we'll get you next week
excellent so same time same bat Channel
um guys everybody in the comments thank
you so much for joining us this evening
it's nice to see you Steve it's nice to
see you Shelly Bob been some bloody
funny comments as usual if you think
every stuff I have to avoid looking at
Bob's comments because he'll send me on
tangents
uh Bob all right
um but um but I love him to death he
comes up with some marvelous ideas
um
Stargate canine Corps I said I don't
know what that's about but it's not the
dog and Doctor Who yeah I don't know
what he was anything yeah oh games that
killed off defines it just comes up I
have to I have to try to avoid his
comments uh but Bob thank you so much
and we'll see you next week everybody
else is joining since this evening it's
been a great chat I'd love to know get
into the comments tell us what your top
um favorite episodes of Stargate were or
pick up one for me season and hopefully
we'll be back next week
um that's
um got me excited about Star Trek again
which
I'm so happy strangely wolves got me
excited but Picard's got me like tingly
excited it's just great
Mike thanks so much a whole different
level isn't it I mean strategy worlds is
great but the card thank you thank you
very much Jay I appreciate it
yeah it's been it's been an absolute
Choice sir so we will see you next week
thank you
bye-bye Mike
[Music]